But they are now out of date. They don't deal with the problems.
You can't deal with the environmental problem
through existing institutions.
You can't deal with the security problem in the way that you need to.
You can't deal with the economic and financial problem.
So we have got to rebuild our global institutions,
build them in a way that is suitable to the challenges of this time.
And I believe that if you look at the biggest challenge we face,
it is to persuade people to have the confidence
that we can build a truly global society
with the institutions that are founded on these rules.
So, I come back to my initial point.
Sometimes you think things are impossible.
Nobody would have said 50 years ago
that apartheid would have gone in 1990,
or that the Berlin wall would have fallen at the turn of the '80s and '90s,
or that polio could be eradicated,
or perhaps 60 years ago,
nobody would have said a man could gone to the Moon.
All these things have happened.
By tackling the impossible, you make the impossible possible.
CA: And we have had a speaker who said that very thing,
and swallowed a sword right after that, which was quite dramatic.
(Laughter)
GB: Followed my sword and swallow.
CA: But, surely a true global ethic is for someone to say,
"I believe that the life of every human on the planet
is worth the same, equal consideration,
regardless of nationality and religion."
And you have politicians who have --
you're elected.
In a way, you can't say that.
Even if, as a human being, you believe that,
you can't say that.
You're elected for Britain's interests.
GB: We have a responsibility to protect.
I mean look, 1918, the Treaty of Versailles,
and all the treaties before that,
the Treaty of Westphalia and everything else,
were about protecting the sovereign right of countries
to do what they want.
Since then, the world has moved forward,
partly as a result of what happened with the Holocaust,
and people's concern about the rights of individuals
within territories where they need protection,
partly because of what we saw in Rwanda,
partly because of what we saw in Bosnia.
The idea of the responsibility to protect
all individuals who are in situations where they are at humanitarian risk
is now being established as a principle which governs the world.
So, while I can't automatically say
that Britain will rush to the aid of any citizen of any country, in danger,
I can say that Britain is in a position
where we're working with other countries
so that this idea that you have a responsibility
to protect people who are victims of either genocide or humanitarian attack,
is something that is accepted by the whole world.
Now, in the end, that can only be achieved
if your international institutions work well enough to be able to do so.
And that comes back to what the future role of the United Nations,
and what it can do, actually is.
But, the responsibility to protect is a new idea that is, in a sense,
taken over from the idea of self-determination
as the principle governing the international community.
CA: Can you picture, in our lifetimes,
a politician ever going out on a platform
of the kind of full-form global ethic, global citizenship?
And basically saying, "I believe that all people across the planet
have equal consideration,
and if in power we will act in that way.
And we believe that the people of this country
are also now global citizens and will support that ethic."
GB: Is that not what we're doing in the debate about climate change?
We're saying that you cannot solve
the problem of climate change in one country;
you've got to involve all countries.
You're saying that you must, and you have a duty to help those countries
that cannot afford to deal with the problems of climate change themselves.
You're saying you want a deal
with all the different countries of the world
where we're all bound together
to cutting carbon emissions in a way that is to the benefit of the whole world.
We've never had this before because Kyoto didn't work.
If you could get a deal at Copenhagen, where people agreed,
A, that there was a long-term target for carbon emission cuts,
B, that there was short-range targets that had to be met
so this wasn't just abstract;
it was people actually making decisions now
that would make a difference now,
and if you could then find a financing mechanism
that meant that the poorest countries that had been hurt
by our inability to deal with climate change
over many, many years and decades
are given special help
so that they can move to energy-efficient technologies,
and they are in a position financially
to be able to afford the long-term investment
that is associated with cutting carbon emissions,
then you are treating the world equally,
by giving consideration to every part of the planet
and the needs they have.
It doesn't mean that everybody does exactly the same thing,
because we've actually got to do more financially
to help the poorest countries,
but it does mean there is equal consideration
for the needs of citizens in a single planet.
CA: Yes.
And then of course the theory is still that those talks get rent apart
by different countries fighting over their own individual interests.
GB: Yes, but I think Europe has got a position,
which is 27 countries have already come together.
I mean, the great difficulty in Europe
is if you're at a meeting and 27 people speak,
it takes a very, very long time.
But we did get an agreement on climate change.
America has made its first disposition on this
with the bill that President Obama should be congratulated
for getting through Congress.
Japan has made an announcement.
China and India have signed up to the scientific evidence.
And now we've got to move them to accept
a long-term target, and then short-term targets.
But more progress has been made, I think, in the last few weeks
than had been made for some years.
And I do believe that there is a strong possibility
that if we work together, we can get that agreement to Copenhagen.
I certainly have been putting forward proposals
that would have allowed the poorest parts of the world
to feel that we have taken into account their specific needs.
And we would help them adapt.
And we would help them make the transition to a low-carbon economy.
I do think a reform of the international institutions is vital to this.
When the IMF was created in the 1940s,
it was created with resources that were five percent or so of the world's GDP.
The IMF now has limited resources, one percent.
It can't really make the difference
that ought to be made in a period of crisis.
So, we've got to rebuild the world institutions.
And that's a big task:
persuading all the different countries
with the different voting shares in these institutions to do so.
There is a story told about the three world leaders
of the day getting a chance to get some advice from God.
And the story is told that Bill Clinton went to God
and he asked when there will be successful climate change
and a low-carbon economy.
And God shook his head and said,
"Not this year, not this decade, perhaps not even in [your] lifetime."
And Bill Clinton walked away in tears
because he had failed to get what he wanted.
And then the story is that Barroso, the president of the European Commission,
went to God and he asked,
"When will we get a recovery of global growth?"
And God said, "Not this year, not in this decade,
perhaps not in your lifetime."
So Barroso walked away crying and in tears.
And then the Secretary-General of the United Nations
came up to speak to God and said,
"When will our international institutions work?"
And God cried.
(Laughter)
It is very important to recognize that this reform of institutions
is the next stage after agreeing upon ourselves
that there is a clear ethic upon which we can build.
CA: Prime Minister, I think there are many in the audience
who are truly appreciative of the efforts you made
in terms of the financial mess we got ourselves into.
And there are certainly many people in the audience
who will be cheering you on as you seek to advance this global ethic.
Thank you so much for coming to TED.
GB: Well, thank you.
(Applause)